movie not only spends 40 seconds lo
going but then tax on another almost 10
seconds repeating text versions of the
same things
why can't movies just movie already the
original title for this movie was
tonight he comes and with either titled
it sounds more like adult entertainment
than a mediocre superhero film
apparently before he was brick this kid
who should probably be at school or
something went around sarcastically
waking up superheroes waking up
superheroes do you ever get that
not-so-fresh Prince feeling cuz in this
movie Will Smith is a certified
douchebag movie has to establish that
Hancock doesn't give up he's avoiding
everything else that's been in his way
up to this point so why wouldn't he fly
over or under the interstate sign that
he could have easily avoided nothing
holds up better after 10 years then a
good old-fashioned Soulja Boy reference
also somehow I doubt this gang has ever
in any way cranked that your head it's
going up the drivers ass his head is
going up your ass your head is going up
my ass
Hancock centipede since everyone seems
to know who Hancock is one would assume
they also know what he can do
so why would they think shooting him
would result in anything other than them
getting their asses kicked
after all that shooting how would their
only be three bullet holes in the
sunglasses how are the sunglass lenses
even still there they should have been
blown to pieces after ricocheting off
Hancock's forehead they decide not to
speak English until now this guy clearly
flew up to their vehicle and rip their
freaking roof off over the angry police
lieutenant brings up a valid point what
does Hancock's motivation in doing this
he obviously doesn't care about much is
drunk off his ass most of the time and
is hated even when he does get involved
so why does even bother and what this
would say to the public is that your
company father topsis permit topsis did
they seriously name their company pharma
topsis rama topsis sounds more like a
disease itself rather than the company
that might cure it this Dunkin Donuts
product leasman is bad enough at face
value but it's even worse considering
this movie takes place in 2008 and LA
didn't know how to Dunkin until 2014
yes I'll see you in about 20 minutes
oh it's national how can you be such a
complete moron to be stopped on a train
track with alarms going off and a clear
line of sight and an oncoming train and
yet you somehow don't know day and
you're the grand marshal also unless
that train is completely automated he
just killed every single human in there
by stopping it that fast we call that
the complete inertia Ronin why didn't
you just go straight up in the air with
a car in honor of random spectator lady
who would be excellent cinemasins here
are four other ways hancock could have
easily superheroes this rescue better
considering he had time to knock on the
hood before doing anything flip the car
and just get out of the way to let the
train pass grab ray from the car throw
the car out of the way then catch it as
you let the train pass hold the car with
Ray over your head and step out of the
way as you let the train pass push Ray's
car and the cars in front of him out of
the way as you let the train pass you
saved my life this is my wife Mary you
find out later that these two are
inexorably drawn to each other
so how was Hancock not running to Mary
the whole time he's been in LA and why
hasn't she gotten ready to leave the
city at anytime after she found out
Hancock was there what are you doing
bullies take your right foot bring it
right up catch him in his little piss
pong make sure he can't use that thing
for nothing but a flap to keep the dust
out of his butt crap I did not teach
anatomy at superhero school does this
mean only men can have clean butt cracks
no breaks things Mary is extremely
casual during the conversation offering
a nonchalant warning to ray but stopping
short of what someone who's well aware
of the potential damage of ray working
with Hancock would do a 20 second
establishing shot for this RV who do you
think you are Danny Villeneuve the real
opportunity missed in this movie is that
we never get to see Hancock playing his
outdoor drum kit Hancock has superpowers
and virtually every part of his body but
even he can't avoid a vicious hangover
I know Michel is a dick and everything
but why the hell would he call Hancock
out for just landing and messing up the
street seems like this is just a cheap
excuse for Hancock to exact vengeance on
Aaron's behalf also the kids are the
only ones on the street so none of the
adults in the houses nearby I heard the
comet like landing one more time in
Michelle's defense I think this is just
how all French people greet Americans
seriously this kid survives this right
about this this is Walter the gray whale
everybody remembers nan buffering 2008
era HD YouTube I don't care how strong
you are unless Walter the whale already
had rigor mortis set in
there's no possible way to get a giant
whale airborne I it's extremely flexible
whale tail it's a simple matter of
weight ratios also whoever shot this
video has perfect zooming and tracking
skills it's not a crime to be an ass but
it's very counterproductive we beg to
differ
what springs to mind when you see this
homo homo in red Norwegian homo that's
norwegia homophobic law it's the law mr.
Hancock and you are not above it staff
and now this Nancy Grace position life
here can be difficult for me after all
I'm the only one of my kind I mean could
the movie foreshadow this obvious plot
twist any harder ok pine they don't like
him because he put them in prison but in
what universe does it make sense to
Hancock block in here since you know
he's a freakin superhero right so at
least one of these dickheads are dead
right did you shove a man's head up
another man's ass but apparently Hancock
faced no repercussions for this action I
know he's a superhero and this is an
unusual situation but can the movie at
least pretend to jail correctly why do
you always laugh picturing you looking
at the maritime movie has time for this
why is Ray constantly allowed to visit
Hancock it's not like he's his lawyer or
anything
he's a PR consultant
no ball thrown from that distance would
hit the rim and circle around it like
that that's a Miss also if it's this
accurate shouldn't that shock just go
straight through
why is discount dead shot even hitting
the rim in the first place yeah good
good Jeff the Sesame Street in goes on
for sometime Gail watch day five and
true to his word Hancock remains
incarcerated meanwhile crime is still on
the rise considering no criminal seems
to be intimidated by Hancock at all I'm
not sure how crime was ever down in the
first place
Mary is still acutely aware about the
danger of her being around Hancock but
goes out of her way to make this visit
to the jail this movie is rocky foring
in cars three it up all over the place
with these fucking montages and what
it's not doing is fucking hand cocking
so has there even been a trial scheduled
Hancock turned himself in but he hasn't
been sentenced or anything shouldn't he
be talking to an actual lawyer instead
of ray unless that ball was made of
flubber there is no way it bounces
further off the rim than it was thrown
live he has no idea how to physic sure
his fingernails might be super-strength
but considering his hair is also just
dead cells shouldn't it be just as
strong
I'm just saying shaving with one's own
fingernail should relatively be the same
for him as it would be for anyone this
was already to this level of bad and how
did Hancock have time to shape where
these bank robbers always planning on a
standoff looks like they brought heavy
artillery massive cases of ammo and an
explosive vest for every hostage if you
have to read a u-haul for your bank
robbery you're doing it wrong brannad
Hancock is impervious to bullets but why
is his uniform we already saw that his
sunglasses could get shot up and his
clothes could burn if this standoff has
been going on a while how are there
still FBI agents running through the
line of fire shouldn't everyone either
be dead safe or pinned down by now just
pack up and leave man honestly Hancock
is taking so fucking long to save the
day that these assholes could be five
miles away before even gets to the bank
why does just one dude get the mask I
guess Hancock prefers to be a jump
scaring dick to the kidnappers instead
of you know saving the hostages
[Music]
seriously you were just shooting at
Hancock you know he's there how is this
confusing this is a spring-loaded
Deadman switch if my foam comes off it
boom how is this the best plan wouldn't
the hand release the switch once it was
chopped off considering he's so fast can
he just grab the guy's hand keep your
hand on that trigger this cop acts like
it's perfectly normal to be handed a
detached hamp
job
you good job this is where the movie
turns into every other goddamn superhero
story ever we don't want to see the good
guy Hancock because that's essentially
Superman we want to see him get drunk
and break we get it Peter this
rotational shot serves as the beginning
of Hancock's redemptive public arc but
could you stop the ride before I damn it
too late only thing I had my pocket was
bubble gum two movie tickets Boris
Karloff's Frankenstein the scene right
here is the reason that despite this
movie's flaws I wouldn't be mad at a
sequel these three are so good together
and Charlize is killing this performance
somehow subtle enough not to spoil the
twist and yet powerful enough to know
she's feeling something deeply 80 years
ago Oh
shouldn't ray at least have been able to
figure out Hancock has been around for
80 years and all his research he's not a
good PR guy I mean Hancock just had that
moment with Rett where they expressed
mutual admiration and respect and he
goes downstairs to immediately Mack on
his wife
I guess this proves the superpower of
boners is greater than the power of
friendship not that this isn't a
well-executed twist but it's such a big
twist it completely changes everything
about the film all of the sudden the
first hour doesn't seem to matter
considering that fridge has been out
since last night and you live in
Southern California
unless you're making Salmonella surprise
for breakfast you should probably just
leave those eggs alone this towel is
definitely not this towel
I mean continuity stuff is it my bread
and butter but how do you not use the
same towel in consecutive close-ups as
strong as he is isn't this a pretty
dangerous way to confirm his theory
depending on her powers this charlize
kebab could have ended very poorly okay
you go away you leave my family this is
really what Mary wanted why didn't she
have this bookin talk with him way back
when they first met yeah Mary's
flip-flopping on Hancock is the most
annoying part of this movie
my place is for Clark whatever let's not
exchange useful information like we're
Hancock's place is located we're gonna
go find Hancock and get your power back
Lou he really should have gone back to
the drawing board and figured out some
more interesting villains than these
three assholes how did no one see Mary
flying all the way from the suburbs to
Hancock's place so Mary's superhero
uniform is basically super smoky eye
shadow Wow
God's angels different cultures call us
by different names basically whatever
their work for asshole is what is this
not the popping popcorn isn't a cool
superpower or anything but why does he
have this many containers of Jiffy Pop
just sitting out on the counter for
brother and sister Wow sisters don't
kiss brothers the way you kissed me last
night first off the kiss last night
lasted for a fraction of a second which
would be exactly how sisters kiss
brothers also either did Mary even tell
him this lie in the first place
doesn't do anything to lessen his
curiosity and actually causes all the
bullshit that happens at the end of the
movie would it have been really worse to
say that they were previously married
stay away from me and my family you are
not gonna do this to me again
pretty sure Mary is out it at this point
so this threat rings a little hollow
call me crazy one more time so crazy for
Mary and asshole for Hancock did each
deity come pre-installed with their own
not safe word I'm sorry
well this relationship went from unknown
to traumatic quickly why have we been
spending over an hour on Hancock the PR
project when we could have been
exploring this so which is less
believable but they just happen to land
right next to Ray's building or that
they would be able to clearly see him
all the way up there this is very hard
to explain well then maybe you should
have started before the last twenty
minutes of the movie we're drawn to each
other no matter how far I run he's
always there he finds me it's physics
physics sounds more like metaphysics to
me or a legendary tale of old or plot
convenience yeah definitely that last
one you know what this movie could use
another huge game-changing plot twist
with just 15 minutes left also I know we
find out that his powers lessen because
of his proximity to goddess Theron but
even if it's somewhat progressive he
literally just crashed through a
building earlier that day how did that
not even injure him also also shouldn't
all his powers be affected I was able to
throw that guy across the room so easily
or zagnut missile that other guy's face
you would think after being a lot of all
these centuries Mary would have learned
to cook something other than spaghetti
and meatballs and becoming mortal it's
never happened before
and why is that exactly seriously the
end of this movie brings up way too many
questions that it doesn't have time to
answer every time we're together they
come after you through me Mary is now
been exposing for over three full
minutes and she still manages to play
the pronoun game so we don't know who
they are
since we know hook-hand was in the
elevator with these two earlier why
aren't he and his cronies already here
as well
policy of the cards keep pointing alive
you to protect this world so why didn't
one of the gods come down and let
Hancock know this so he wouldn't be
wandering around drunk for the last 80
years wondering what his purpose was yes
the TV mentioned earlier that these
prisoners escaped but are we supposed to
believe that all three of these guys
could just saunter up to the hospital
room of the one person the cops would
almost certainly know they were coming
after and he just casually back through
that wall setting aside the question of
if he's strong enough why would the
entire wall explode if he's just slowly
moving through it wait do they feel each
other's pain - not only did Mary Mary
quite exposition areum never mentioned
this in her five minute break down
earlier we've never seen anything
indicating this in any other previous
injuries has he just been standing
around that corner this entire time I'm
assuming every bad guy gets a handbook
detailing how long to wait in these
situations for maximum effect except for
the super-strength that ability to fly
but yeah other than that sure no
different they use acts machina this is
all build up for Hancock part two we're
airing after losing his mom and hero
turns to a life of heroin and male
prostitution eventually becoming a
serial killer the goal is to get away
from Mary so she can recover might I
suggest the stairs I hear there are
fewer buses also why does this even work
Mary was nowhere near Hancock when he
got shot at the plot convenience store
earlier so immediate proximity shouldn't
really be the key what about a tale of
the hunt completely cross eyed Queen
Elizabeth M Dean just because you've
been around a while it doesn't mean you
would have met every single famous
person unless you're the doctor or Bill
and Ted the original inspiration for
Ryan Johnson's salt planet is revealed
cool and eagle which we still don't know
the significance of or who's trying to
kill them or how the other pairs died
perhaps we could have answered some of
these questions instead of spending the
first hour of the movie worried about
drunk fresh prints
so the truth
after all I'm the only one of my kind my
skull was fractured kouchtown population
you bro
call me crazy one more time come on good
huh come on do it
lay out right here do it do it